hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play tune in Bruce Lee all right
we're going down this I got a bad
feeling I got like a seriously bad eye
a jar fuel Oh for the thingy oh okay
yeah I can deal with that how do I get
out of here
every door's locked every door is locked
I don't even have
[Music]
[Music]
stay the [ __ ] down down wait wait where
did that come from
where do you where'd you come from
cotton-eye Joe
[Music]
here huh okay yeah is it okay wait what
is that
ah I knew there
[Music]
man guys I swear a media has not scared
me in a while this this mod I swear
go get on that rock
yeah I don't know what it is about this
moment I think the pacing is like
perfect like the whole beginning part
never saw a monster and that's like the
first time I've really can I see
anything that's like the first time I've
really encountered a monster and boy how
many damn I mean damn
okay okay over there okay all right oh
yeah I'm stay the [ __ ] down
that was one okay
a third open the gate I see
and there's another gate okay okay Hey
look at that I haven't been down here
lots of torture devices ah hole in the
ground I want to go down there I think
that leads to the I don't know I'm
actually running out of torches what I
saw one right there oh no I didn't I'm a
liar okay all right uh I'm better now
I'm not gonna not gonna be a little baby
I'm so brave and tough so pray Oh Tom
don't hear anything down here
no steep stairs
and goodies like hitch nope okay fuel
good because I got plenty weight way so
much fuel man like jump down here okay I
thought stay on the [ __ ] ground
okay got it
well this looks downright Pleasant dunno
was wrong with the other area the
doctor's office looks downright good
chair honcho Oh two notes I have to take
care of the bodies from yesterday feed
the prisoners the code to the castle is
high fives 9 report to land that's my
doctor boys bit of a mess the addition
of our city wok weather my set of tools
has been quite beneficial I see down
encountered a bit of snack during my
last experiment as expected the
application of the acid the flesh
produces an immediate violent reaction
causing intense burning sensation Oh
kidding one subject seemed to believe I
had to set him on fire
adds additional acid for Yahoo Rosa
effects caused large portion of the
subjects skin to seal off all the
remaining portions of skin become
necrotic ha ha producing a distinct red
scarring upon extended exposures about
right yes all of this is characteristic
of an acid of this potential I do lift
it but I seem to have just
underestimated just how much the body
last session it was quite certain of all
six subjects had died due their extended
exposure that the acid was wrong that
her breathing must have been slowed to
the point of near death so how they
managed to remove their restraints after
I had left
that sounded like the voice actor for
the guy I'm playing maybe they're just
doubling up I like my my doctor voice
best
oh yeah the code duh code which was five
five six nine that's why those guys look
so mangled you spied on her sit a [ __ ]
you get out of here
the spiders are weird sometimes they do
skitter around and other times they
actually come after okay this is where I
remember seeing this before but I didn't
go down here oh it's the bull fire
[Music]
ha ha ha can you look okay am i learning
[Music]
hey Jimmy matches hey okay let's imagine
huh dude who's I bet you I'm begging you
I'm gonna I can boost you Hey
but boosts you in arming fishing oh that
maybe some people supposed to have over
that gave it is he gone
alright that was weird and freaky any
say in a devotion point yeah that's it
I'm better now
controls okay what's this
Cody's five five six nine that's just aa
hello here found you I found you
man I tell you this this this this mod
it's not really a custom story to my to
this mine is crazy crazy how much stuff
they put in I'm loving it I love this
mod like no joke it's one of the best
I've ever played I haven't been this
scared or the ambience is perfect
I love the new stuff they put in I don't
know I made this point me later but for
right now it's great back should I
should be good
huh
ah
[Music]
okay oh god I gotta get up before he
kills me huh he's gonna murder me well
he's gonna kill me
murder like me gonna murder me you gonna
murder me get out get out ahh hey buddy
hey grandpa
oh boy oh no no no no
no but either way he's free what was the
point of even coming through there
besides freeing a maniac well it could
have gotten out at any time I suppose
oh where is this a Czech mixture is this
Lex I think there's like secret places
and this places that you know you don't
have to explore but where's the body
there's a spiral stair case again oh
yeah this is the first dead end okay
there's it's nothing I don't think I can
get to it like in the other area that's
just since I'm getting out here I got
the code that's it that's all we got
it's all she wrote yeah here's ah her
book yeah no spare not gonna give me
okay that's actually all the time I got
for this episode thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next part
bye bye